he's literally right by the Trap what is
going on here so the line must have came
out of the one trap that we were in and
it just swam by that one okay we're good
fast gets out of here no he's right here
he's right here he's right here swivel
oh God he's swimming at the boat he's
easy easy
I got the quiver
getting out of here
oh gosh we got mono back we've been
working this fish really hard we've had
to untangle him out of several with lots
of traps but we're still on the line
here tighten up the leash so we can only
get a couple hundred feet away but
there's so much gear we're not in a
pumpkin patch we're on a sour patch
we're not in a Cabbage Patch we're in a
lobster patch
there he is get over there he's huge
coming this way Tyler it's close he's
like 35 40 feet away this fish ain't
ready to quit
a lot of Life still in them and he's big
I mean this thing's big 600 700 pounds
got a really good look at this fish big
sickle fence this is a big one this
Line's already been compromised quicker
we can get this fish to come up quicker
Tyler can put a dart in it he's straight
up and down at this point but he's doing
dramatic turns he's going up down all
around into the patch out of the patch
back
doing good just battling this fish he
doesn't want to give up this is a tough
bite
oh my god there he is the Behemoth murm
it's a behemoth it's been a clawed
obstacles here this just Lobster gear
everywhere it's just driving us crazy
it's total pandemonium there he is huge
color coming up easy
he's big he's huge mom he's really big
he's doing a nice big pinwheel when you
see him to do one more
get some good something
he's a biggie
drill them
Norm I got him he's big it's huge
freaking it's six seven hundred pounder
man this is what oh my God
this is what makes it go right here
[Music]
right in our backyard let me get the
tail rope on him
by far the biggest fish of the season
right here to the true goats right here
we don't just catch baby tuners we catch
them everywhere another new spot for us
this season big boy coming up on big bow
big fish big boy that's a big fish look
at how big this fish is oh my god wow
what a beast how long it's wide what a
huge fish it's gonna be a big payday I
didn't get any of these down there at
Chatham
[Music]
thank you